i want to turn now to young people
america's most
reliable non-voters now americans tend
to preserve their voting
chastity until their 30s which of course
makes conservatives very happy stay pure
young people
save your vote for your husband right
but i think this year
could be different here to talk about
that is actress producer and change
agent
yara shahidi welcome yara welcome to the
show hey
thanks for having me it's so great to
see you i was like who's this grown
woman on my show
i think the first time we met i was 13.
it's crazy
that's actually my first question
because you've been speaking out and
speaking for
like a lot of these important issues for
a while now and i want to know
what happened to that shy little girl
that i cast at that
as that narcissistic materialistic
teenager where did you get all this
activism yes exactly where did this
activism come from
honestly i do genuinely credit blackish
because
i come from a really humanitarian family
you've met most of my family yes
if not the entire like tree yes um but
i come from a family that's always
talked about civil rights i've had a
grandfather at the forefront of the
civil rights movement within his
community um and so there was always an
expectation
that regardless of where you ended up in
the world that somehow you're
going to orient your job towards social
justice but
the reason why i think blackish was so
pivotal is that i don't know
in any other situation a time where they
would have handed a 13
14 year old a mic to say what are your
takes on police brutality right
if i wasn't on a show that was already
starting that conversation and so
i think really the transition was that
moment in which i was able to have these
conversations that were already
happening privately really publicly
because of the nature of what we were
covering and then i think
people got used to just hearing me talk
yeah
yeah you were always so thoughtful i
know kenya and i noticed that from the
beginning
you were always talking about finishing
school and the way you talked about it
and i wanted to ask you about
gin zeirs if i can lump you guys um
what's happening right now they're more
young people like you
that have the same sense of urgency or
do you think there's more genders who
have the cynicism you know where they
feel like their generation has been left
with table scraps
i feel like it's a fair mix of both
quite honestly
and i think one informs the other
feeling like we've been left
with table scraps feeling like okay well
climate change
is now a pressing issue that will affect
us within our lifetimes
all of these issues of racial justice of
immigration are things that affect us
i think the one thing i have noticed of
gen z and i hope i'm not just making the
observation true of my friend group but
i feel like
for the most part we have these wider
networks so whether an issue directs
that
like directly affects us we have more of
a tendency to care deeply because
more than likely we do know somebody in
our immediate circle who is of that
identity group or of that intersection
and so with that being said there is a
level of urgency created from the
cynicism
and it is an interesting task of like
well how do we make this cynicism
productive
um how can we use that feeling to be
like okay we already know that
depending on how many electoral votes
your state has for some reason votes are
diluted because of gerrymandering
whatever the issue may be
right but then what is our general
action plan and i think
that's where gen z and just how
vast our network is really does come
into play because there are some people
that are galvanized to take to the polls
there's some people that are like
okay well i'm going to be actively
protesting we saw over 100 days of
sustained protests
against racial injustice and so all of
that
i feel like adds up to create a
beautiful just kind of groundswell of
action in every space
yeah and as a woman of color in the
business and out in the world i've
noticed that you seem really conscious
about the black and brown issues that
face our community too
do you feel a certain responsibility
about that or or it's like
hey that's what's there you know that's
just what i gotta do
well i call it a sense of really
indebted gratitude if i can
try and name it that's great that's
great and yeah it's something i've
reflected on
just from even having within my own
family
the people who quite literally fought
for my rights and then
i think expanding that to think of the
i don't know insurmountable amount of
people of many generations who fought
for my rights whether or not they knew
me personally
i am definitely the result of
a work that people knew had to be done
regardless of whether
it was a future they were guaranteed the
ability to see yeah
and i think because of that there is
there is a sense of
a deep sense of care being black and
iranian and
constantly trying to figure out what
that means in different spaces
wanting to at the very least um continue
to be of service because
what we do know unfortunately is that um
the idea of justice and progress is
never stagnant and just as much as we
can go
forward within action we can go
backwards and so i
i like to think of i believe it was
britain pac-net who
had said something on a collective call
we had together of saying you know to be
socially engaged it's like going on a
moving walkway and you have to
actively run the other way it's not
enough to just kind of stand still
yeah and she's been on the she's been on
the ground floor of movement she was in
ferguson
you know when all that erupted you know
is that beginning of black lives matter
tell us about you know when you sat down
we noticed your t-shirt the we vote next
which i know
is yeah there it is yeah tell us about
that is
is this something that you started yeah
so i started revo
next really inspired by the 2016
election
because i was too young to vote i could
bring my parents to the polls
but it felt like that was about the
extent of it and i feel like
the feeling um that it evoked was
feeling like the government was
something that happened around me rather
than with me
and what we know to be true is that
level of disenfranchisement
unfortunately doesn't go away when you
magically become eligible to vote
because of the structures at play and so
part of it was like well can we create
an organization where we at least
can grow together and begin to
understand how
these systems are in place together and
so
inspired by the fact that we had a
midterm election in 2018
which was my first election i could vote
in it was like well how do we engage
young voters
yeah um who care about just so many
different issues to come into a room
together
and to be extremely honest about what we
know and what we don't know and without
any sense of shame being able to be
empowered when we go to the polls yeah i
saw your interview with uh stacey abrams
it was inspiring to see how passionate
you guys were
you were like sisters who hadn't talked
in a while you know
right dude i sure felt that way and it's
funny how somebody like that
you know they kind of inspire you to
want to do more and everything have you
thought about like once this election is
over like how do you connect with young
people
to let them know that civic engagement
continues
after moments like this well what's
funny is i feel like this is
actually a sentiment that's widely
shared by young people especially
because of what we've gone through
in these summer months um not to say
that racial injustice was something
invented in february
but we've almost moved so far past
where our ballot is in the past some
months alone
yeah um and so it's been an interesting
conversation and i think there's so many
youth leaders and leaders in general
who have done such a great job at
talking about the fact that
voting is to be used as an active tool
it's never going to be perfect
right like you're saying knowing that
civic engagement is a daily task
it means that election isn't an end date
but really a start date and
what we want to do is make sure that the
tools and the people that are in office
are once will at least work along with
us
as we get to whatever that future looks
like yeah it's it's people knowing that
it's not
it's not just that their vote matters
it's their involvement matters and for
people to sense that involvement
what are your top maybe two or three
issues for you personally
you know if you could wave your magic
won do you or maybe it's just one
issue in particular hmm that's really
difficult
um to say i feel like
if i were to be so broad it really is
the issue of like
what does equity look like i think we're
at a moment and
just i've been reflecting on this as of
late it feels like one of the ills of
white supremacy
is the ability to take away our space as
black people to imagine
and to engage in serious imagination
yeah an example that i
use really randomly is that sir isaac
newton must have been
so bored and so unencumbered yes to come
up with calculus
that's brilliant and i think of the fact
that that feeling
of being unencumbered hasn't been
granted to us and so
uh really i think the biggest question
is the question of imagination
because we're no longer engaging in
conversations on
what's the quickest reform but we're
engaging in conversations on
what's the next sustainable change
that's going to drastically shift how we
do everything and as we
engage in the new normal i feel like the
idea of protecting space to imagine
for this next iteration of the world to
be inclusive is a pressing and dire
issue yeah and privilege is is not
having
to eat that apple that falls on your
head right
you created an entire course of study
based on something you couldn't even see
exactly and somebody funded that when
that was what 400 500 years ago how long
ago was that
[Music]
you